couple of them from the data structures
and algorithms program and a couple more
Quantum e talks or Quantum related
trucks and but the first talk will be
given by bensonatura on Fast exact
solids for LPS
yeah thank you I'm visiting from Georgia
Tech and um let me jump right in to a
problem that is very much related or
say at the core of my research and there
is a special case of linear program uh
classical problems that we all know and
that is pipette matching so far no way
it's just easy we have habitat graph we
have on one side workers a and the other
side tasks B and we want to assign
workers to tasks subject to
um yeah at most a worker is being
assigned to at most one task and we want
to maximize the tasks that are fulfilled
um very classical problem how
efficiently can we solve this problem
and the first question I'm asking is
okay how fast can you do it in the
number of edges of your graph and in
terms of L where L is the big complexity
of the numbers appearing in my input but
here there are not really numbers so L
is one
and the answer is okay we can do that in
this polynomial running time and
classic it's 70 years old okay can we do
it in almost linear time in terms of the
number of edges in our graph and that is
a very recent breakthrough result yes we
can do it
um
I think a solution is even the audience
here okay now what I'm yeah often
interested in is can you drop the
dependency in the bit complexity now
here it is not really a bit complexity I
mentioned that already so in fact the
above is already
an algorithm that solves the problem in
runtime that is polynomial in the number
of edges okay
now let's
turn it into a weighted problem now all
my edges have weights so we have certain
costs to assign workers to to tasks
um and this costs are say integral for
our purposes and now it changed a bit
the this constraint here to say I want
that all tasks are assigned and subject
to that I want to minimize the cost
that's classical related by budget
matching problem how efficiently can we
solve it
um first question okay can we solve it
in Running Company normally in the
number of edges and the bits now the
bits are meaningful because my costs can
be arbitrary and so it turns out we can
do it again classical algorithms just
Advanced carbon as an example can we do
the linear time subject to still having
dependency and the bit complexity and
the answer is yes again
um this is again the Breakthrough result
from last year does apply again okay
um now can you drop the bit complexity
on L because this result here has a
running candidates logarithmic in the in
the uh in the size of c and the answer
is again yes and there again many
classical algorithms the Hungarian
algorithm does it or lean's algorithm
that is more general for minus flow does
it as well so here we can solve that
problem in periodic time okay now let's
add another twist to the problem also
classic but less studied and that's the
following
um also all my edges now have
efficiencies so let's say not all
workers are equally efficient to fulfill
a certain task you know some people are
specialized on something and now these
efficiencies are just numbers that are
not negative
and now I want to again assign workers
to tasks fractionally such that all
tasks are fulfilled where fulfilled
means now that if I assign an x a b
fraction of a worker to a task then a
gamma X fraction of the photo task is
fulfilled okay now this makes a bit more
complicated
um now how efficiently can we solve that
again running some polynomial the number
of edges and bits yes we can do it but
now we need a bit more heavy machinery
namely it's a linear program and linear
programs can be solved in running time
in general that is polynomial number of
edges or polynomial number of variables
and the in the bits okay can we do it in
almost linear time and the answer is is
no you don't know how to do it and now
the question is can we do it without
depending on the bit complexity of my
problem so without depending on the cost
and the gain factors and this is very
recent uh result of us that we can
actually do that in uh so-called
strongly polynomial time
in fact it's a bit more General but this
will come in the next slide and I'm
happy to give a long talk here in the in
the seminar semester on this
unfortunately I'm in the organizer of
the seminar so
you have many seminars so maybe someone
else could invite me to their seminar
okay
um yeah so this was a special case of
linear program and the story is a bit
different for people who like dependency
in the bit complexity and for people who
don't like it
um for me I'm more in the
um don't depend on the big big
complexity uh side of it and um if you
like dependency complexity well then
well you can do it in putting on your
time you can do it very efficiently
almost optimally in the sense that you
can almost do it as fast as linear
system solving in certain instances
um up to dependency on the big
complexity of course but on the other
hand it is not known whether there is a
general strongly polynomial time
algorithm for LP where you would drop
the dependency in the bit complexity
okay what we know is that it can solve a
strongly polynomial time if my Matrix is
nice in a certain sense so if all my
entries are integral and not too large
where this is a very general generous
definition of too large the entries are
allowed to be up to two to the poly and
okay and now the new result is that we
can also solve and strongly polynomial
time if every column contains at most
two non-zeros so this is a bit actually
it's it's vastly more General than what
I had on the last slide because it would
apply not only to bipartite graphs but
to General graphs but and also not only
for directed graphs but also for
undirected graphs so yeah that is the
the results
okay
um
and um
yeah I
need a b
size of a size of a is included in B yes
yes right so it's a generalization to
something based on say separation
articles
um
can you can you make this question
precisely
well you said it applies to non-bipar
digraphs as well yeah
I mean just forget about drugs just
think of a matrix that has at most two
and zeros to come yeah all right well I
don't want to hold you up okay okay
um yeah and now um there's the slide
that you knew showed last time and I'll
just write a new update to this now so
if you're interested in swimming
fundamental algorithms versus weekly
polynomial then what did we have before
uh last year is all these classical
combinatorial problems
um and um a few more
let me not explain them here people who
work on these node definitions of course
um and also when we are on small
Dimension and it turns out that there is
one algorithm that
that a strongly polynomial for all of
these and there were two special classes
that we don't know yet how to solve
especially putting on your time one is
General Mark of decision processes and
one was the two non-zero entry per
column uh problem and now I can move
this to the solvability to the to the
cloud that is solvable
um which brings me immediately to the
open problems that are still there in
the area and that is of course can you
solve mdp and strongly problem real time
um and beyond that I would be interested
in in the following problems
um there is this Gap now since last year
between strongly polynomial servers and
weekly polynomial service that is linear
so for even for single Source shoulders
path
when you have Negative Edge weights then
Batman Fort is the best thing you can do
to solve and strongly put it on your
time which is order and n and we can put
a number of time we've seen the results
in order M there's even another paper
that is more combinatorial that also
achieves order M for the minimum cost
flow the same story even if it's in
theory it should be more complicated
than single Source Shutter's path
in both worlds weekly and strongly
polynomial they have the same running
time as single socialist path so can you
break this linear gap between weekly and
strongly polynomial and this question
you can generalize to General LP if I
allow sort of a bit complexity
dependency on the constraint Matrix but
not on my objective or my right hand
side then what you can do in general is
that if you have a class within your
programs that you can solve in running
time that is some function of the
dimensions and the number of non-zeros
and then this polynomial in the bit
complexity of a b and c then you can
turn this into a strongly polynomial
time algorithm
that does not depend on the big
complexity of B and C anymore but now
has a additional quadratic term in
running time so MN comes in the front of
it
um of course we see that for graph based
problems this Gap is linear but here it
is quadratic so question would be can
you reduce the screwdriver Gap to
something that is that is smaller
okay and I guess I'm at the end of my
head off
[Applause]
you have time for a couple of questions
the question Phil was asking what kind
of access are you assuming to a like is
it like a decoration
yeah can you you know make sure these
things go through if you have just like
separation it's hard to do things
exactly when you want to have a
separation
so I hadn't thought about that yeah
thank you this is a very nice can you
tell me um if I understand correctly
with more than two let's say three
variables per column it's as general as
any is that is that believed or known oh
it is it is it's the same as you can
search reduce to to three sets in the
same way you can reduce any LP uh by
quadratic blow up or cubic lower blow up
to an LP with three variables per
inequality so two is the most you can
hope for before you solve the whole
problem super yeah thank you
any other questions
so the problem you solved is not
solvable in linear in the number of
edges uh we don't know you don't know we
don't know yeah
thank you
all right thanks again
[Applause]